[Musique]
le nouveau coronavirus le sera ce kof 2
serait-il le résultat d'une manipulation
artificielle ou encore du génie
génétique
c'est en tout cas le genre de théories
évoquée récemment par l'ayatollah ali
khamenei en iran qui voyait l'action du
gouvernement américain ou encore un
sénateur américain qui a pendant un
certain temps cru et laisser croire que
la chaîne crée le virus sans oublier un
porte parole du ministère chinois des
affaires étrangères qui avançait que le
gouvernement américain cachets des
informations sur les origines du virus
qui aurait été importée selon lui à
houran par l'armée américaine en octobre
dernier
bon dans tout ça il ya notre collègue de
siby cylindrée à bellemare qui a mis les
choses au clair dans un article récent
et souligne que nouveau rapport de
recherche d'une équipe internationale de
scientifiques publiées dans le journal
nature medicine conclut bel et bien que
le corps n'a virus qui causent lakovic
19 n'est pas un résultat du génie
génétique
l'équipe il ya comparer les données
génétiques du nouveau virus à celles
d'autres cordes à virus et a trouvé que
la manière dont le strass cov deux se
lient aux cellules humaines indique
qu'il a évolué de façon tout à fait
naturelle
si le sera ce kof de avait été manipulé
on s'attendrait à ce qu'il y ait une
relation plus étroite avec d'autres
virus connus oui il existe d'autres
cordes à virus semblable mais celui qui
se rapproche le plus de l'asra skov 2 en
termes de génétique a seulement été
découvert après le début de la pandémie
actuelle
alors d'où vient le nouveau core anna
virus à l'origine de la coved 19 mai les
données existantes tendent à démontrer
qu'il est semblable au virus de chauves
souris ce qui fait des chauves-souris la
source la plus probable du virus actuel
mais d'autres recherches scientifiques
seront nécessaires pour le confirmer
alors des questions vous trotte en tête
en voyant certaines informations ont
circulé sur le web
écrivez-nous décrypteurs au pluriel
radio tirait canada.ca et consultez
notre groupe facebook et notre page web
salut
[Musique]